[MUSIC PLAYING]
HAYLEY DENBRAVER: I'm a
developer advocate at Snyk,
and at Snyk, we want to
help you use open source
and stay secure.
And because we eat,
breathe, sleep security,
we've chosen this
intimidating-looking guard
dog for our logo.
But as a developer
advocate, it's
my job to be more like
this golden retriever--
friendly, approachable,
helpful, really wanting
to talk to you about open-source
security, so that's my goal.
Right?
And feel free to
say hi on Twitter
because I'd love to chat
open-source security with you.
So today, we're going
to do a few things.
First, we're going to do a very
brief overview of serverless
and how it compares to
some other solutions
you might have encountered.
Then I'm going to show you
a demo app that I built,
and then we're going to hack
it, which is my favorite part.
And finally, I'm going to
give you a few takeaways,
so when you go and build
your serverless app,
you have a few things to keep
in mind to help keep it secure.
All right.
So when you're working with
a cloud provider like Google
Cloud Platform, there's
a few different ways
that you can organize your app.
And there are kind of pros
and cons to both, or to any
of these, and we'll kind of
do a quick overview of each.
So a monolith is what
I would kind of see
as a more traditional solution.
This is where your team
handles the virtual machines
and your apps run on that and,
you handle the operating system
and the security questions
that arise within the operating
system.
So you have to make sure that
you stay patched so you're not
leaving yourself vulnerable.
And the Cloud Platform very
nicely handles your hardware
and there's just easier
elasticity and host setup.
OK, this is working out.
So with containers,
it's pretty similar.
Your team's going to handle
your virtual machines.
But within those virtual
machines, you have containers,
and those containers can have
different functionality in them
and each container can have
its own operating system.
So it's just a little
bit more flexible
and you can spin up a new
container if you need it
but you don't have to scale
the things you don't need.
And the Cloud platform,
it handles your hardware,
you handle the operating
system, but it's more flexible.
And this system is more
portable and it's easier
elasticity and host setup.
And finally, you
have what we're going
to talk about today, which
is a serverless setup.
And in this kind of
situation, you only
really need to worry
about your app, right?
So you worry about your app
and the functions inside of it,
but the Cloud Platform
handles your virtual machine,
it handles your
operating system,
they handle the hardware.
You don't have to think
about operating system
management, your host setup.
This is the best
cloud portability
and has maximum elasticity.
So this talk is about serverless
security, and you may wonder,
well, I have given a lot
of the security concerns
over to Google Cloud
Platform and they're doing
a really good job with it.
So what's left for me to secure?
And well, I want you to
think about your application.
And this may be a
broader consideration
than you may at
first think, right?
This little chart here
I have, the yellow
represents the code
that you wrote.
But the code that you write is
not the entirety of the code
that you ship.
OK?
The big blue circle represents
the code that you ship,
and the part that isn't
the little yellow dot,
well those are
your dependencies.
So let's take an example.
In one of Snyk
serverless demo apps,
we have 222 lines of code.
And that's really trim.
Not much to survey, and
you could look and find
security problems pretty quick.
But in addition, we have
five direct dependencies,
and because those dependencies
have dependencies,
we have 54 total dependencies.
And you might shrug at
this but it actually
adds up to nearly
half a million lines
of code, which is a lot, right?
And how many security
vulnerabilities
are within those half a
million lines of code?
All right.
So Google Cloud
Platform is going
to secure the operating system
for your serverless app,
but you need to consider
your application security,
and you need to consider all
of it, not just the yellow dot.
So let's take a look
at my sample app
and we're going to hack it.
All right.
Because I like a bit
of whimsy in my life,
the sample app is a to-do
list obsessively written
by my cat to make sure that
I do all the things that he
requires.
OK?
And I have a function
within this app that renders
the to-do list really nicely.
So you can see we have the
start of that to-do list here.
And if I wanted to add
to this to-do list,
I can hit the HTTP point
with a simple cURL command.
We already have Feed
Cat on the list,
so we're going to say Feed
Cat again because that's
just how it works.
And so we see that
an item was created.
And when I refresh this, it's
going to show the new task.
Right?
And this is awesome.
Jacques, he's going
to add as many things
as he wants to, right?
But maybe I don't
like that so much.
You know, I'm the boss,
he's not the boss, right?
So what would happen if I
want to take this app down.
To cut it off at its knees.
And I'm going to show
you how we might do that.
So first off, I'm going to
show you Snyk's website, where
I've uploaded this app.
It looks at the
dependencies within the app
and it scans them and it
lets me know when there
are known vulnerabilities.
So within my dependencies,
there are actually
nine known vulnerabilities.
There may be more but these
are the ones we know about.
They have CDEs, all
those different things.
And some of them, we
can exploit and get in.
So the one we're
going to look at
is a regular expression
denial of service.
So this vulnerable module,
MS, it's in our app
because it helps us parse
time fields, kind of.
So to give you an
example of that,
let's say my cat really
wanted to take a nap
but he wanted to be woken up.
So he's going to add an
item to the to-do list
of wake cat in two days.
So he's going to
take a nice long nap.
And so we do
another cURL command
and it creates another
item on our list.
And we can see it
here, wake cat,
and it recognized two
days as a time period
and so that's why you see
that formatting there.
Right?
And we could build
functionality around that to,
like, send out a reminder or
something along those lines,
right?
However, I'm kind of fed
up with this whole thing
and I'm going to try to
create a to-do item that it's
going to take the system
too long to do matching.
Right?
So let's see.
So I'm going to use
this cURL command, which
tries to add a to-do
item to provide snacks
in an amount of time
that's really long,
and just to keep it chugging
away and trying to figure out
what's going on a little bit
longer, I misspelled minutes.
OK?
It says here, minutey.
So let's see what happens then.
Well, nothing.
Right?
It's still chugging
along, trying
to make a match
somewhere and trying
to do its regular
expression thing, right?
But while it's running
like this, my cat,
whether he wants to or not,
he can't add any new to-dos
to my to-do app.
And so I really appreciate
that and I'm just really glad
I was able to stop him
in his tracks just using
this simple regular expression.
Right?
So I'm going to just kill this.
So once again, I'm the
master, not Jacques.
So let's go back to
the presentation.
So I have a few takeaways
that hopefully you
can use when you're writing
your next serverless app.
And briefly there, number one,
beware of vulnerable libraries.
Number two, deploy granular
functions and permissions.
Number three, don't rely
on function ordering.
Number four, don't
rely on immutability.
And number five, to worry
about all functions.
So first off, beware of
vulnerable libraries.
Test during development
and monitor over time.
This is exactly
the kind of problem
that I just took
advantage of when I broke
Jacques' to-do list, right?
And here's a little
snippet of the Snyk website
and you can see that it'll
list out the vulnerabilities
and give you a little
report about them.
And so then you know.
And it also will tell you
what remediation can be taken.
Right?
So this is a very important
thing to be aware of.
Secondly, you should
deploy granular functions
and permissions.
It's safer.
So think about today.
You were able to come
down into this space
because you have a badge.
I'm looking out and you
all have badges on, right?
But your badge doesn't
get you into the entirety
of this space, right?
There are doors and things that
you need a special badge for
or a different colored badge,
something along those lines.
It would be madness
to issue everyone
that came to Google Cloud Next
just a generic, like, you're
allowed everywhere badge, right?
And it's the same here.
Deploy granular functions
and permissions.
Don't let everyone
access every function.
It's just better.
All right.
Don't rely on function ordering.
Every function is a perimeter
that needs to be secured.
And when I think
about this one, I
think about how I don't not
lock my safe just because I've
locked my door, right?
Don't rely on these
initial functions
to protect the ones that are
maybe further in your app.
Right?
Every function has a perimeter
that needs to be secured.
Fourth, don't rely
on immutability.
Assume servers can be reused.
And just in general, don't
make assumptions that
could compromise your security.
All right?
And finally, worry
about all functions.
Every function increases
your attack surface.
Let's say you have a
house that has ten windows
and you were very
diligent and you
alarmed and locked eight of
them but two of them are open.
Or maybe they're not open
but they're just not locked.
Well if you have something
of value in your home,
the eight highly
secured windows aren't
going to deter someone
who wants to break in
to get what you have, right?
So it doesn't matter that
you've secured those eight.
What matters is that there is
a way in in those two windows.
So finally, just one
more quick review,
be aware of
vulnerable libraries,
deploy granular functions
and permissions,
don't rely on function ordering,
don't rely on immutability,
and worry about all functions.
Also, don't let your
cat boss you around.
So thank you all.
And again, I'm Hayley Denbraver.
I'm a developer
advocate at Snyk.
Feel free to say hi
on Twitter @hayleydenb
or to follow my
company Snyk @snyksec
or to check out our
website on snyk.io.
You can try the tools that
I showed you for free.
And yeah, thank you
all for being so great.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]